The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information about our
license and MIT OpenCourseWare,
in general, is available
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Last time, I started to talk
about the heat equation, also
known as the diffusion equation.
And what we did then
was to solve it.
Give an analytical solution.
Both for any initial
value u of x and 0,
and then, specifically
for the point source.
So then, we're talking
about the impulse response,
or the fundamental
solution, when
we start from a delta function.
And, it was that Gaussian,
bell-shaped curve.
Fantastic fundamental solution.
But the formulas
you get involving
infinite integrals are not the
greatest for actually getting
numbers for the
whole temperature
history, u of t and x.
So we have to go to
finite differences.
And, of course, we need
finite differences also
in more general cases, where
non-linear terms could appear.
Or even just variation in x and
t in the linear coefficient,
which I had just set to be 1.
So, this is the first job.
Difference methods
for the heat equation.
And you'll see that we get
pushed toward implicit methods.
Because explicit method
will require delta t
to be that very small
size delta x squared,
and that's pretty slow-going.
And of course, what I'm
saying applies equally to --
we might be in 2D or in
3D diffusion of pollution,
for example, in
environmental engineering.
Our fundamental solution
from the delta function
would easily extend to
two dimensions or three.
And, our difference
methods will extend,
but we'll see what comes up.
And then, let me point to
this second problem which
combines the two.
We already know
about one-way waves,
coming from a convection term.
Now we're getting the basic
ideas for the diffusion term
and lot of very important,
real problems combine the two.
And then you have a
situation that I'm just
sort of pointing to.
Here, that
coefficient, as before,
has the units of velocity.
Distance over time.
You see, if I
bring time up here,
I have time over distance there.
So I need distance
over time from c.
It's what we've seen always.
And, then the c delta t over
delta x, the quantity r,
was dimensionless.
So, I'm taking three minutes
to speak about dimensions.
Dimensional analysis is a
very simple but useful thing
to do at the beginning
of a problem.
So here we had r equals c
delta t over delta x, which
is dimensionless.
And, typically for
explicit methods,
it had to be bounded
by 1, for example.
Now, for the diffusion term d.
What are the units of d?
Well, here, now I have distance
squared in the denominator,
so d needs to be a
distance squared over time.
So it has different dimensions,
and the quantity capital
R that we'll meet,
parallel to this,
will be d delta t
over delta x squared.
And, again, it's dimensionless.
Because if d has dimensions
of distance squared over time,
that reverses it to give
dimensionless quantity,
and we'll see that
explicit methods require
a bound on capital R, and
that's what so forces us
into that small time step.
OK.
So you'll see capital R playing
a similar role to little r.
And actually,
while we're talking
about dimensional analysis, back
to the differential equation,
suppose we want,
as we certainly do,
to compare the importance
of the convection
term and the diffusion term.
Well, that comparison is
somehow the ratio of c to d, So,
somehow, it's natural to
think of the ratio of c
to d as telling us a
very important fact.
Is our problem more
like a wave problem?
Do we expect to be on the
unit circle, or close,
with a term that in Fourier
space is pure imaginary,
from the i*k?
Or, if d is big, we
have then a small ratio,
and that tells us that the
diffusion term is important,
that we've got lots
of dissipation,
that the stability, at least
in the differential equation,
is much greater, because this
is producing a minus k squared
in Fourier space, and a
strongly negative term.
So it's that ratio c to
d but of course, my point
here in the dimensional
stuff is that c to d
isn't quite OK as it is, because
they have different units.
And we need one more distance.
So we need the ratio of c
-- where do I need an L?
I need another L up there.
I need another distance
there to get something that
is altogether dimensionless.
And so that's the
critical number.
And, it's a known as
the Peclet Number.
Pe, I'll call it.
What is L?
We're talking here only about
the differential equation. l is
characteristic length.
If our problem is set
on a finite interval,
then it's probably the
length of the interval.
It's a characteristic
length of the problem.
And, then this, quantity c*L
over d gives us a good measure
of the importance of these two.
And, we'll see in the
finite difference case,
there will be cell
Peclet number,
which is entirely different.
A Peclet number for the
little finite different cell,
where this L is changed
to like a delta x.
OK.
I think we've got it there.
Have I got the numerator and
denominator correct there,
or should they be reversed?
Is it time over distance?
It is, isn't it?
Time over distance.
That shows that I'm not
a dimensional analyst.
Let me fix it.
And, then that will
mean fixing this.
So, let me just fix that.
It doesn't sound right as I
said it, but I read it wrong.
OK.
So c is a time over distance.
Thanks.
Is that right?
It was right the first time?
In that case, we'll move on.
OK.
All right.
Good.
Thanks.
Yeah.
You're right.
OK.
Sorry that's on the tapes.
So now let's begin with
a natural explicit method
for the heat equation.
What everybody would think of.
So, this will be explicit
for the heat equations,
and I'm in 1D.
And, what do you think of?
Naturally, forward
difference in time.
So, can I write it this way?
Time difference -- I'll
use capital U, as always,
for the finite difference
solution -- divided by delta x,
and I'm doing the heat
equation with c equal to 1.
Just to keep things
simple, let's just
do the heat equation normalized.
So, here I'm going to
take a second difference
in the x direction of u
divided by delta x squared.
OK.
What's the accuracy?
Well, we know the
accuracy of each term,
the centered difference, the
error is the discretization
error, the local error,
the truncation error,
it's also called, will
be proportional to -- oh,
I'm sorry, that's
delta t of course.
OK.
So, the discretization error
in a forward difference,
when I divide by delta t --
so it's first order in t,
and centered difference because
of the symmetry is second order
in x.
OK.
And this would be
another problem
where I could have begun
with a semi-discretization.
I could have begun
with keeping this
as a derivative, du/dt, equal
this centered difference,
and the discussion would have
been entirely parallel to what
we'll have here.
So, I've jumped right to the
finite difference in x and t.
So, in other words,
what's happening here?
U_(n+1), U at that center
point, n plus 1, of course,
our little molecule is computing
this backward difference,
and this -- or rather
forward in time,
so this is the time
direction, n plus 1 --
and this centered
difference in space.
So if I just write out
what that does, it's u_(j,
n) coming from the
time difference.
Then, I'll multiply by delta t,
and I have a delta x squared,
so that ratio is what I'm
calling capital R. Capital R,
to distinguish the diffusion
ratio from the wave ratio.
Times what?
So it's just going to be U_(j+1)
at time n minus 2*U_j at time
n, plus U_(j-1) at time n.
We're good at writing
that expression down.
We can follow e to
the i*k*x, of course.
That's always the idea.
Start with U_(j, 0) as
e to the i*k*j delta x,
and follow it up.
We're looking for
a growth factor G,
the growth factor
in a single step,
and, of course, the point
is, it depends on k.
At at every step, the
exponential is always with us.
It's the factor that multiplies
that exponential that we want,
and you see what
it is, don't you?
Can you see what G is here?
So, if I put in that, and
then ultimately factor out
the exponential, it'll
be multiplied by a 1,
from that part, and an R from
this, and now in parentheses,
we have the now very familiar
quantity that comes from e
to the i*k delta x, e to
the minus i*k delta x.
Those combine to give
2 cosine k delta x,
and the center one is minus 2.
OK.
That's our growth factor.
And the question
is, does it stay
below 1, which is the stability
requirement, for all k delta x.
And, so you can see the
dangerous frequency as,
often, the dangerous frequency
is when k delta x is pi,
and that cosine becomes minus 1.
And, then we have -- So,
stability at k delta x equal pi
needs -- so this becomes
1 and this is negative 2,
and that's negative 2.
We have 1 minus 4R,
and that quantity
has to be, in absolute
value, not exceeding 1.
Well, there's no danger that
it's going to go above 1.
The danger is, will
it go below minus 1,
and it's not allowed to.
So we need it to be greater
than or equal to minus 1.
And, now, if I put the minus
1 on this side and the 4R
on that side, that means 2
is greater or equal to 4R.
And, I get the famous condition
R less or equal to half.
That's the stability
requirement.
And if there was a coefficient
d in the heat equation,
the coefficient would
be there in R. OK.
So, that's the
stability condition,
and that's the thing we would
like to find a way around,
because, it says
that this delta t --
I'll just put that in,
less or equal a half,
and that means a
very small delta t.
OK.
What's the way around it?
To go to an explicit method.
So, let me go first to a
completely explicit method.
Fully explicit.
I'm sorry.
To go to an implicit method.
Now, implicit method --
now I'm going to do --
switch to an implicit method
by computing this difference
at time n plus 1.
So this is now n plus 1.
And, what's the change in G?
A big change.
OK.
So now I want to recompute
G, for the growth
factor over a single step
for the exponential, when
the right-hand side,
the second difference
is taken at the new time.
So this has to move over to
the other side of the equation.
That makes the stability
better, but, of course,
it's going to make the
computation more difficult.
Let me just think about
the stability for now.
So, instead of this board,
this is the explicit case.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So it has to be,
let's draw a little picture
here.
So, there's 0.
There's 1.
And here's minus 1.
And this quantity is starting
at 1, and subtracting 4R.
So, the question is,
does it stop here?
If it stops there,
then in this picture,
these would both be negative.
This would be
about minus a half,
but that is greater
than minus 1.
So this would be the OK
case, when this is true.
And that's what required
R less or equal to half.
So in this case, yeah.
In that case, R is less than
-- but if R equal to half --
everybody sees this --
if R equaled a half,
this would be 1 minus 2.
This would bring us
all the way here.
And if R is bigger
than a half, then that
would reverse that inequality,
and we would be unstable.
Yeah.
I think it's OK.
Thanks.
It's the difference between
looking at the magnitude --
if I put magnitude, then I
would need less or equal or just
realizing that it's just
taking it as a number.
1 minus 4.
OK.
I think that's all right.
Now the implicit case.
What happened to G?
Let me put it here.
Implicit.
So, what's changed?
This term, which came from
the second difference,
is moved over to the n plus
1 side of the equation.
So, we have -- in Fourier space,
we would have 1 from the u_(j,
n+1), and then minus 2R, and
times our expression 2 cosine k
delta x minus 2 -- that's
what multiplies e to the i --
do you see that that's
showing up on the new side
of the equation, multiplying
e to the i*k delta x,
and on the old side, the old
time step, we only have the 1.
In other words,
the growth factor
is, this goes down
into the denominator,
and we can see what's going on.
So the growth factor is
1 over this expression.
1 minus 2R times 2
cosine k delta x minus 2.
We keep running
into that quantity
from the second difference.
OK.
So if I look at that,
what's going on?
The key point of
this quantity is
that it's always negative,
or zero, but never positive.
Because this term is never
as large as this one.
So it's negative.
And now, I have another
minus sign here,
so I have 1 divided
by 1 plus something.
And always, for all k and
all ratios R, it's OK.
Right?
1 over 1 plus
something positive.
And you see that
everything's real.
That's because we're doing
the diffusion equation, where
the wave equation took us,
we had some imaginary part.
Absolutely stable.
Stable for all delta t.
I'll say even for large delta t.
That's good.
Of course, we're not going to
take delta t equal to 1000.
Even if stability allowed us,
the accuracy would be hopeless.
It'd be terrible.
I can't take a giant time step
and expect to follow the true
exponentials for e to the i*k*x.
But, I can take a larger step
than this very small delta,
one half delta x squared step.
So this good.
What's the price that we pay?
The price is that at every
time step, we have to solve.
This is now on the other side,
so this brings a whole matrix
over.
So, this implicit case -- when
I bring this second difference
matrix over -- I've
used capital K,
because the second difference
matrix there is probably
the most interesting
difference matrix, I'll say.
One of the most interesting
matrices, period.
It has the minus 2's
on the diagonal and 1's
above the diagonal.
So, actually, with
signs exchanged,
I called it K. So
can I just remember
the meaning of
this matrix K. I'm
going to stay with that
letter because it's
standard in finite elements
for the stiffness matrix.
So, K, by definition, is
the matrix with the 2's
on the diagonal, minus 1's above
the diagonal, and minus 1's
below the diagonal.
And, what size is it?
On the whole line, where
we're working for simplicity,
I guess K is infinite
in both directions.
2's and minus 1's.
On an interval where we
would really compute,
K would be a finite matrix.
But, the main point is
that this matrix K is minus
the second difference matrix.
So that when I bring it
over to this side, which
changes that plus to a minus,
I get this equation to solve.
The identity, coming from
the 1, plus R, the ratio,
times this matrix K,
multiplies this vector
of all the values at
the new time step,
and equals, in this case, all
the values at the old time
step.
Because, at the old time step,
I just have the identity.
Are you OK with this?
This is the problem that
we actually have to solve.
I mean, the main
point about it is
that we have a linear system.
The u's at the new
time step are coupled.
Coupled by the
second difference.
Coupled by the matrix K,
so we have to deal with it.
Well actually, in one
dimension, no problem.
Because in one dimension, K
is just a tri-diagonal matrix,
and we can solve
tri-diagonal systems
almost as fast as we could
work with the identity matrix.
And actually, what we're
seeing in this ratio
are exactly the eigenvalues
of the inverse matrix.
So, if I use a formula, I would
say U_(n+1) is the inverse
matrix times U_n, and the growth
factor is just the eigenvalues.
The growth factor G is
simply the eigenvalues
of this inverse matrix.
And, notice again, that
all the eigenvalues of K
are greater or equal zero.
It was a positive
definite matrix,
because I switched sign.
And, the effect
of the identity is
to push it a little
more positive.
Here.
It's making -- this is
a positive number there.
That's the eigenvalues
of R*K, and then,
I making it a little more
positive with this 1,
so we have a problem that is
safely invertible, stable,
and in one dimension,
quite simple.
So in one dimension we're
entirely ready to go implicit.
Let me just, while
I'm thinking about it,
recall that we had some other
matrix in the finite matrix
case, we had some other matrices
in the very first section
of the original notes, which had
different boundary conditions.
In other words, if we're
on a finite interval,
then this matrix K corresponds
to zero boundary conditions.
Zero temperature at the end.
But we might have other
boundary conditions,
like the derivative
of the temperature
is zero at one end,
or the other end.
That would change this matrix in
the first row and the last row
to another nice matrix.
So, we might have not K but
one of the other tri-diagonal
matrices.
But, here's the real point.
What happens in two dimensions?
Suppose I include now a u_yy
term in the heat equation,
or three dimensions
with a u_zz term.
What's different?
Well, we can follow
through the stability
test for the explicit
method, and it'll all
have a term from
delta x squared,
and a term from delta y
squared, and a delta z squared.
It'll be even slightly
tighter on delta t.
Or I can follow through
the implicit method, where
now this second difference
in the x direction
appears also with a second
difference in the y direction
and a second different
in the z direction.
So what's happening?
From the matrix
theory point of view,
I still have nice matrices with
2's and minus 1's or maybe with
-- I guess what we would have
-- can we just remember what we
would have in the
two-dimensional case.
In the two-dimensional
case, instead of
this second difference with
a minus 1, a 2, and a minus 1
in the x direction, we also
have a second difference
coming from the u_yy in the y
direction, so another minus 1,
and that 2 moves up to a 4.
So our matrix in the 2D,
two space dimension case,
will have a 4's on the diagonal.
So it grows from this one.
It's called the tensor
product coming out of this.
Anyway, it produces this
famous five-point molecule
with 4's on the diagonal,
and four minus 1's
going down other diagonals.
And the problem is that
those diagonal are not --
two of the diagonals might
be right next to the main
diagonal, but the other
two will be farther away.
Because we can't number
the nodes to keep all
these four numbered adjacently
at all the mesh points.
In other words, we have
a serious matrix problem.
That's my comment.
We have a matrix K in 2D.
So what I'm speaking
about is this problem.
Identity plus R*K(2D) u at the
new time equal u at the old
time.
And K(2D) is by no means so
easy to deal with as K(1D).
It doesn't have a nice
narrow band like this.
The band stretches
further, and we'll
see in spades, in then next
part of the course which
is about solving
large linear systems.
So we have a large
system because we've
got lots of mesh points.
We have matrix that
has a wider band,
and so you need new
ideas in solving it.
So this problem is what will be
a model -- is the connection,
really, between this
section of the course,
difference methods for
initial-value problems,
and the next section, which is
solving large linear systems.
Because this will be a typical
model large linear system.
So that's a comment that
for implicit equations,
the price was low in 1D, but
the price is not so low in 2D.
OK.
Now, have we got
any other candidates
between explicit and implicit?
Well, we did, way back,
for ordinary differential
equations, we had
a trapezoidal rule.
And what did that do?
That increased the
accuracy by centering it
at time n plus a half.
Do you remember that?
It was half on the
right-hand side;
we used half the
explicit difference
and half of the
implicit difference,
so natural to do it again.
It worked then,
and it'll work now.
So this will be the
trapezoidal method.
But most people in the
diffusion application
name it after these
authors, Crank and Nicolson.
So it's the
Crank-Nicolson method.
It's half the explicit part
plus half the implicit part.
And the order of
accuracy is increased
by centering it this way.
That's the point, of course.
So I guess the point
will be we don't
have any extra work compared
to a fully implicit one,
and we get an extra
order of accuracy,
by centering it at a half.
So u_(j, n+1) minus u_(j,
n) over delta t is R,
that ratio -- oh sorry.
We've got delta t there -- so
will be the second difference
at the old time times a half --
it would just take half of that
explicit part plus half
of the implicit part --
this is at time n plus
one, over delta x squared.
You would think of that.
Everybody would.
It's just a natural idea.
It increases the accuracy.
It's still implicit.
We still have to bring this term
over onto this side when u_(j,
n) moves over onto that side.
And we can look at
the growth factor.
So that's what we have to do.
So bring that term over,
and bring delta t up,
so it's delta t divided by
delta x squared and R. OK.
So I've got this term.
The 1.
And when I bring
that term over, it's
a half of what we
brought over before,
which was the R, 2 cosine
k delta x minus the 2.
That multiplies G.
And on the right side,
we have the 1 from the
u_(j, n) plus the half,
times the R times 2
cosine k delta x minus 2.
I'm certainly getting to the
point where I write these
expressions down faster without
explicitly writing e to the i*k
delta x and then canceling it.
So, G is a ratio again.
In the explicit case G
was all in the numerator.
There was no denominator.
In the fully implicit case,
g was all denominator,
with just a one
in the numerator.
Now we have G as the ratio.
So I'm going to bring
this down below.
And, G is a ratio.
So it's a fraction
because it's got
an explicit part in the
numerator and an implicit part
in the denominator.
And, of course,
the main question
is, when is G less
or equal to one?
Well.
Actually it's cool, because
G is simply -- look,
the numerator is one, and
all this stuff is negative.
So this is one minus something.
And, what's going down here?
The signs just reverse.
It's one plus something.
And this is a positive
quantity, and this
is the same positive quantity.
So, this is one minus
-- do you see this --
because this is negative, I'll
write it as 1 minus something
-- something positive.
And here, this is minus
and this is negative,
so this is 1 plus
the same thing.
So what's the answer?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
One minus a positive number
over 1 plus that positive number
can't go wrong.
So, for all R. OK.
In a way, that has to be more
attractive than fully implicit,
because it didn't
take more work,
it wasn't any less stable,
and it was more accurate.
So Crank-Nicolson is
sort of a natural idea
at this level of analysis.
OK.
So those are the three
methods to think about.
Of course, actual computations
will bring in new questions.
Boundary conditions,
non-linearities,
and everything.
I'm just staying at
this simple level,
where I'm comparing the first
ideas that would occur to us.
OK.
We may want higher accuracy,
all sorts of things.
But, we're seeing the contrast
with the wave equation case.
But, here we move more
toward the implicit side,
and the reward is unconditional
stability, no condition on r,
but the price is
more computation.
OK.
Well, at that same level
of thinking about the most
natural methods
that occur to you,
I want to speak now
about the big, big issue
of convection-diffusion.
Suppose both types of
problem are with us.
So convention-diffusion.
What would you do then?
Now, I have both convection and
diffusion in the equation u_t
equals c*u_x plus d*u_xx.
And I guess I want to say
that this is something
that the world has not
come to a decision on.
The computational
world is still debating
what to do with
convection-diffusion.
So it's a very appropriate
equation model to experiment
with.
Maybe I'll ask you, as the
next, kind of informal homework,
to begin to
experiment with that.
And when I say experiment,
you can think immediately
of the methods you
might think of.
The first methods to try.
So the first method of
course, will be explicit.
Fully explicit.
What do you expect
to have happen there?
Let's just see how the
two different terms
each give their little
push towards the stability
requirement.
So explicit is going to be
the time difference, forward
time difference equals c times--
what shall I choose first
for the space difference?
Upwind, maybe?
Upwind in space?
So, this is going to
be explicit and upwind.
Of course, everybody knows
that refers to the windy term
in the equation, the wave term.
OK.
So, of course, I'll get a
forward difference, then,
in the x direction of u
at time n divided delta x,
and then I'm going to
do the natural one.
A centered second difference at
time n for the diffusion term.
OK.
We'll see what
comes out of that.
It's going to involve
not only the ratio,
it will involve both
ratios, naturally.
Little r, as soon as I
multiply up by delta x,
I have a little r there,
my wave equation ratio.
And I have a d delta t
over delta x squared,
which I'm calling capital R.
That's the diffusion ratio.
And multiplied by
all sorts of stuff.
So actually, why don't I write
down what the equation really
is then?
Explicitly, it's u_(j,
n+1) is u_(j, n) --
so maybe I should collect
all the terms here.
Can I collect the terms
that multiply u_(j+1, n)?
So what's going to
multiply u_(j+1, n)?
Here I have a c
delta t over delta x,
I have an r, from this term.
And here I have a d.
Right?
No.
Sorry.
I have a capital R.
Isn't that right?
When I multiply through by delta
t, I have d delta t over delta
x squared.
I have a capital R that's
going to multiply the --
does that look right?
And then what multiplies the
center guy, the u_(j, n)?
Well that's where the time
difference comes over.
There's the usual 1.
Then from this difference,
this upwind difference,
there's a minus at
the center term,
because it's a
forward difference.
So that will be a minus r, and
from this centered difference,
well remember, that that's
a second difference,
so there's a coefficient 2 in
the middle term, or minus 2,
and when I bring the delta t
up, it's minus 2 capital R.
And then, the third one,
whatever this last coefficient
is, is multiplying u_(j, n-1),
and now, where does that come?
It doesn't come from
here, it doesn't
come from the
upwind difference, I
guess it only comes from there.
And it's probably
just R. And I guess
I would check any
formula like that,
to be sure that the
coefficients add to 1.
And they do.
And why should they?
Why should those
coefficients add to 1?
So that's my little test
that I've got it right.
They should add to 1, because
a constant initial -- if u_(j,
0) is a constant, if I'm
starting from a constant
function, its x derivatives
would all be zero.
If I had u equal constant,
then the x derivatives
would be zero, so
the time derivatives
would be zero, so that
constant would stay forever.
And so I would want to
get the same constant out
from constants going in.
And so the coefficient
should add to one.
Well.
I can see a situation when
I know stability will be OK.
Stability can't fail if those
three coefficients are all
positive.
If those three coefficients
are all positive,
then my growth factor
can't be larger than 1.
Those coefficients,
they add to 1.
So the growth factor
is this times --
should I write it down?
The growth factor
will be this --
so this will be the
growth factor --
G will be that number
times e to the i*k delta x,
from shifting over one.
It'll be this number times 1,
and it'll be this number times
e to the minus i*k delta x,
and my point is just that
the easiest estimate would
say, well this has magnitude 1,
that has magnitude 1,
that has magnitude 1.
If I just add up
magnitudes, I'll
get this one, and
this one and this one.
And if they're all positive,
they add to 1, I'm safe.
So what's the
stability condition
that this simple
argument requires?
Well.
That's positive.
The danger is this one.
So I guess I would like
that to be positive.
So I would want -- I'm certainly
stable if this is positive,
which I might as well write as
r plus 2 big R being not larger
than 1.
Because if that's true,
I'm taking a combination
with positive coefficients
adding to 1, I can't go wrong.
OK.
And in fact, that's
pretty familiar.
It combines the two
conditions we know.
The condition that r
should be less or equal
1, small r, the wave
Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition.
And the condition
that capital R should
be less or equal to half
the diffusion condition.
Now they're both -- now
I'm forcing them even more
by saying that the sum
has to be less or equal 1.
OK.
So let me leave the explicit
upwind at this point,
and ask you what other
method might you want to try?
Well, it would be
natural to think
of explicit centered,
where you would center this
and we could follow
that one through.
I guess I'll do that
next time very quickly,
and the notes will do it.
And I'm not sure which of
those two ways is better.
Or, you're going
to say go implicit.
And now I'm going to ask, all
right, but what part of it
do you want me to make implicit?
Maybe all I need
to make implicit
is the heat equation part.
And I can keep this
explicit perhaps.
And I could even think
of splitting the step.
This is something
we haven't done.
I could think of taking a wave
step and then a diffusion step.
Whatever.
Putting them together into
one step, where the diffusion
step is changed to implicit,
because of the great stability
that that provides.
OK.
I think you're
seeing the reality
of scientific computation
even at this fundamental model
level of a model with two quite
different physical effects
of motion with finite speed,
energy preserving, magnitude
of G tending to be right
at 1; and diffusion
at infinite speed, giving
us a growth factor that
tends to be real and
below 1, but the price
is it pushes us toward
implicit methods.
I think that's really -- this
one choice that I've worked
through, and the others
that I've mention,
present a real problem.
I'll say another word
about this topic next time
and then we'll pretty
soon move to non-linear
equations and more realistic,
more difficult applications.
OK.
Thanks.